welcome back to the morning toast we are
so excited to be sitting down with
someone we very much respect and talk
about
all the time here at the morning toast
it is kevin o'leary also known as mr
wonderful thank you mr wonderful for
being here so happy to be here this is
this is wonderful
it is wonderful it's wonderful and
wonderful yes
that's great um can you tell us you
brought us a gift you set up this entire
little
moment what is going on here well
today's a very special day in new york
and i haven't been
to new york for over a year because the
whole covet thing
but today my wine company is going
public on nasdaq
through a spac in other words it got
acquired into a public company oh
and that's a very big day for us we have
been growing and growing and growing for
seven years
uh we're now one of the largest wine
companies in north america
and this is a you know big moment
because we'll be making lots of
announcements at four o'clock when i
ring the closing bell
wow any sneak peeks for us yeah i'll
tell you what but let me just put on my
um very important elements when you're
in the wine business
there's a little gymnastic one all right
this is my test event let me explain
what this is
this is when i'm in the cellar because i
blend all the wines or at least the
o'leary ones you're seeing
we go into the oak caskets and we take a
little siphon
called the thief and put a little bit
into here let it
mix with the air taste it and then spit
it out because if you do that for every
battle you're gonna get really wasted
yeah
so that's the whole idea so the test of
ambi has become the symbol of wine
making all around the world
and there's very famous organizations
like the chevellier de testa
i love when you say that on church i'm a
member of and
those of us who blend wines now these
two wines i brought to celebrate with
is my these are my most award-winning
wines and my biggest sellers my
chardonnay
it's more of the montreshe style which
is the french style of making chardonnay
very crisp very light less oak and then
my incredible cabernet sauvignon which
has won award after award after award
wow even andy our cameraman when he got
was proposed to his
his fiancee he took all the insurance
necessary which was two glasses of this
oh my gosh and she immediately said yes
i'll marry you that's right oh wow and
you know what like i feel like you've
kind of made a mark for yourself in
shark tank as the wine guy
and when i met you i feel like a lot of
people don't know this but it's pretty
common you and your wife taught me that
you can tell
what kind of wine is in the bottle based
on the shape of the bottle is that
correct you can you can this is the
classic french cabernet
and that's the classic chardonnay now
what's happened
in america you know the most popular
wines today are the cabernet sauvignon
red and the chardonnay chardonnay
exploded when they started growing the
grapes in california decades ago
and they started competing globally and
and california shards started
kicking french shards butts a lot in
international contests where it's blind
taste testing
so the wine industry the american wine
industry particularly in washington
state
sonoma valley napa valley it's
really a big business now but there's an
old joke about the wine business if you
want to become a millionaire in the wine
business
start as a billionaire because everybody
blows their brains out they make it a
labor of love i'm in it to make
money yeah and the only way you can make
money in the wine business is have huge
scale be able to ship
millions of cases be able to fulfill
costco and target
my own wines and the new trend which
we've really blown up big is
46 states allow you to ship directly to
your customer remember a case of wine
weighs 39 pounds
yeah so if you get it direct it's coming
right to your door
and i have built that business up to
being the largest direct consumer in the
world
wow at least in north america i can't
save a globe yet because i don't know
what they're doing in china
right but i'll kick the chinese butts
too
yeah in covid i mean direct to your home
wine
is every answer yeah and what happened
was people
didn't stop drinking wine during covent
but what
really got crushed was our business tube
restaurants yeah that's when we replaced
it with the direct consumer and
blew that business up even bigger yeah
and now people are saying i don't want
to you know carry 12 bottles back from
the store just ship me another case mr
wonderful yeah
and i obliged so you i think one of my
favorite interesting facts about you is
now you're conquering wine you've very
much made yourself the wine connoisseur
but what you don't get enough credit for
is you were also the original inventor
of a childhood staple of ours the oregon
trail
yes the argon trail read a rabbit where
in the world's carmen san diego
all those titles yes and that's how i
came up that was my first business was
educational software
um oh my gosh i didn't know that yeah
that was it and we used to develop all
kinds of titles
um you know oregon trail was an
incredible product because it started in
minneapolis i think minnesota and i
may have forgotten exactly which city
but i remember when we bought the title
he required it i was blown away by how
rich the storytelling was in it yes your
ox died a sedentary like it was crazy
yeah you know people would try and get
through the brutal lifestyle of moving
west in you know
in that time but we invested a lot of
money into it and made it one of the
standards of 110
000 school buildings in america yes and
we were among those schools right it's
literally a cornerstone like a staple of
millennial
like early education i like a very fond
memories of it yeah yeah
we sold that company for 4.2 billion
dollars very nice
and i started with nothing in the
basement you know sort of a garage thing
and the 10 of us that were founders that
was our big liquidity event
yeah and since then i've made many
mistakes but also made a couple of good
investments too so it was a really big
it was a big moment for us because we
really had nothing and then boom
and i remember the day we went back to
the office and i said everybody going to
do
we can all retire and everybody said i
don't want to retire yeah let's keep
going
so you entered the wine business as a
billionaire well
yes but but i've really
learned a lot um from the wine business
most of the companies that i've made
money with have been run by women
that i've invested in and the wine
business included
i remember um when it started it was
actually a shark tank deal years and
years ago called zip swine
single serve wine of course yeah you
guys went back and forth back
yes and it was one of the famous first
time a guy ever came back twice yes
and but but i'll tell you the story of
that the day after that aired
i won the deal i thought the place to
get this into would be costco
yeah and there's a very famous story
about costco this woman nate
and a woman named annette alvarez who
started
in costco in florida in miami sweeping
floors
she had such an incredible palette to
taste wine
that she quickly moved up the ranks to
the regional buyer and then she became
the
national buyer and then the head buyer
for the whole of costco and what you
have to know is costco is the largest
wine buyer
in the world period not nobody's
bigger anywhere on earth so they get
everything she had 12
buyers underneath her and it was also
known that nobody could ever get to her
every wine company in the world wanted
to talk to her but she just wouldn't
take calls
so after shark tank i thought i wonder
if she's a shark tank fan
and i've got a guy on my staff that goes
into the dark net knows how to get cell
numbers
and so he got her cell number for me and
i called it
and i left her message saying hey it's
kevin aaron shark tank i have no idea if
you uh
watch the show at all but i have this
product called zips i'd like to show it
to you
20 minutes later the phone rings it's
annette alvarez and she says
you were rude to barbara last night
what what does that have to do with
anything she said no we're not doing any
business until you apologize to barbara
wow
i said what did i do wrong she said you
were rude to her you cut her off she was
speaking
i said that happens every day on shark
tank yeah plus you want to have less out
of barbara not more
anyways we made it work and she said
look i'll give you one hour
john wayne airport this saturday and i
want to meet your wife oh wow
i want to know who would marry a guy
like you right i said
okay and i said linda we're going to
john wayne airport we're going to meet
annette alvarez
and here's where it all starts we meet
her we sit down with her she says kevin
let me tell you about the wine business
you don't know
if you want to make money in the wine
business and not be one of these schmoes
that just starts a little winery and
says oh look i got a winery
you have to be able to ship me 150 000
cases in a day
wow i said annette i can't do that she
said you can
if you partner with vintage wine estates
a guy named pat roney
you go cut a deal with him you come back
to me and watch what happens
and she was the woman who gave me the
advice that turned this whole thing and
blew it up and now we're going public
today
wow well congrats yes but i'm just
telling you listen to women sometimes
all the time i'm just so i i shut up and
listen a lot because that was great
great information that's so interesting
and you know because it's very you know
you see you on shark tank it's such a
big show and i think a lot of people
are on the misconception that that's not
all you do you know like you're a famous
person now who made
you know his billions on your
educational company
and now you just are a famous person who
does shark tank but you're still very
much active in a lot of companies
correct
yeah i have 35 plus portfolio companies
across a wide range of activities
everything in commercial kitchens
we do insecticides we've got wireless
charging companies we make
a very famous gym equipment for
condominiums here in new york that
business exploded during cobit
we have the wine business obviously and
many many many others
i will tell you something each day
there's a catastrophe in some part of my
business
you know portfolio some something
horrible is happening and at the same
time
the phone rings and it's some euphoric
outcome and somebody's buying another
one of our businesses
right and it's just like a passion play
every day
yeah you know on one end total [ __ ] on
the other side
fantastic things yeah i've kind of
gotten into the groove now and i say
well
okay that's just the way it's going to
be yeah you can't make everything work
and then every once in a while boom it
hits
it hits big so how many
an estimate how many companies do you
think you've invested in from shark tank
oh it's got to be pro maybe over 100 by
now i've been doing this for 13 years
and how many an estimate do you think
you've made a pretty good return on
well what happens is let me give you the
ratio because we've got all this data
in normal venture capital when when you
you know go to boston and talk
to silicon valley to a venture capital
firm they do 10 deals and you look over
eight years what happens two of them are
absolutely wild successes they make
40 50 times on their money and then
about
four of them um are living dead they're
still in business but they're just
barely getting by barely getting by and
unfortunately waste a lot of your time
and the rest go to zero and so it's sort
of you know 20
work in the real world in shark tank 50
work and here's why here's the secret
sauce
so 50 of our deals make money because
see how we're sitting here doing social
media and you you reach out and you've
got millions of people listening to you
your customer acquisition costs are very
low yes right
we get 100 million eyeballs a year on
shark tank through syndication in 23
countries
so when we put a product on shark tank
it's not uncommon to get all your money
back in 24 hours yeah oh wow
yeah exactly what happens and so our
customer acquisition costs
are either zero or very low so even a
marginal company
a shitty company that can't acquire
customers gets this
jolt yeah of of you know free
advertising
for decades yeah yeah and boom they just
keep selling stuff and we have all this
stuff documented
the rise so the whole thing about shark
tank is getting on shark tank yeah and
if you can get a deal then you get the
updates which are really powerful
some companies i love the updates beyond
the team
we love we love but you know you get
more sales on updates sometimes and you
get on the main show huh
so you want to get a deal that's the
secret sauce to shark tank that's so
interesting what's your favorite
category or type of product that comes
into the tank when you're like
oh i'm listening to this one i love
companies
you know right across the board every
category included
that has already figured out social
media
and direct to consumer sales and they
know their customer acquisition cost
when they walk on that set and say look
we don't sell retail we sell direct to
consumer
and here's our customer acquisition josh
here's the margins we make all i'm doing
then is pouring gasoline on the fire if
they're asking for a million bucks i'm
happy to give it to them
yeah because what's going to happen is
we're going to just blow that business
up because they've solved all the
problems already
like the infrastructure's already there
exactly and the ones that i
those those are the deals i tend to do
anything run by a woman gets priority
for me because i've made so much money
with women i'm just
you know i'm biased in some ways i
shouldn't be but that's fair women
tend to mitigate risk you know that old
expression you want something done give
it to a busy mother
yeah like they can keep a lot of stuff
in the air once and that's what you need
in a small business
and also they're much more savvy on
social media yes i agree
and women are more likely to engage and
share on social so you want a woman
speaking to them and well the same way
you do it you know you connect with
these
you know other people and they they just
want to hear what what's next from you
right well companies that have figured
that out have very very powerful
business models
yeah and so what would you say is your
most successful
business investment from shark tank is
it plated even though that was it it is
it's a new york city
deal in some sense right it was started
here by a couple of entrepreneurs
they came on the show they had a
ridiculous valuation they didn't get a
deal a year later
they run it to me in the street and say
hey listen we've been tenderized by the
real world
right we're willing to cut a deal and so
we do it we do a deal and then they get
back into the tank in a follow-up
and then one day we get a call from
albertsons right after
amazon bought whole foods and said we
need to buy a digital platform
right 340 million smackaroos
wow business is like 36 months old so
those dudes rode into the sunset
that's amazing we love so many of the
episodes where you have guest sharks we
learned so much from them who was your
dream guest shark for the tank have they
already been on
well no no my dream guest shark is mr
wonderful
i love you i love that i love that guy
yeah we've had a lot of guest sharks
we've had all kinds of guest sharks
some are better than others some you
know what happens with shark tank and
this includes all the people that come
and pitch
they you know a hundred thousand people
apply
340 get picked 220 get taped maybe 180
air
wow okay so here's what happens you've
been practicing for months
you know you're going to get on that
carpet yeah
and then you walk out the door
i know you've practiced now it's real
yeah
26 cameras rolling jibs moving down you
know
steady cam all around you and you freeze
yeah yeah
yeah it's sometimes it's painful i have
to say like at least for me
i can think of one episode in particular
that will for me ever go down as the
worst pitch ever
um and he actually went to your college
yeah i think that's why i remember him
he had that app that was like basically
a map of the airport and it would help
you like find restaurants
and he remembered and he was like such a
classic millennial like needing
validation and then he went back and he
was like crying in his mom's arms like
it was just all so
like funny but he sucks and when the app
was like he was going around to
different airports and writing down like
where there was no real like
infrastructure like
do you have like memories or things that
you like always will remember as being
like funny or particularly like terrible
you know i get in a lot of trouble for
being the mean shark i'm not the mean
shark i just tell the truth
yeah when it sucks it sucks yeah okay
and it's very important that they know
it sucks so that they don't do it again
stop sucking yeah like try and come up
with something better
and then come back we've had people come
back but it's really a bad idea if it's
going to go to zero and you take your
family's mortgage down you know
yeah it's just crazy well yeah you seem
like you're very much on like the tough
love side of things
well i'm just the truth and if you can't
deal with me imagine the real world
what's going to do to you
yeah you're going to get fried and so
that's my attitude but you know i got to
listen to barbara
and i got to listen to lori yeah you
know you seem like you love it like it's
a great part of your job
yeah but they you know what they do is
they say well look i'm not going to
invest in you
this is barb all the time i'm not going
to invest in you but you keep doing what
you're doing and i look at her so what
are you doing
like don't you have any morals right
now the only reason barbara gets to the
shark tank set each year is i buy her a
new brew
you guys have such a great dynamic i'm
curious is that
first show and you guys act like that
behind like off screen too
you you all have a crazy dog we're like
friends we've been dealing with each
other for
over 10 13 years so
we try and be cordial i've you know we
but we're competitors yeah we're
competing for deals and and
we like each other and all that stuff um
barbara's a great cook when i'm in new
york i'll often go and have dinner with
her she's great
uh we're also incredibly busy like yeah
i've i've never seen all the sharks get
in a room
during the off-season ever it's
impossible to get them back together not
in for a birthday party
well we can't but everybody's so
everywhere
and so the only date we know we're gonna
see each other all together is the first
shoot date
of shark tank when we just clear our
schedules and we go do it right
yeah it's such a great show it's become
such like a
a part of like american culture and like
business and like business education i
think that especially for us that i
think for so many people like everything
we know about business like
we know from shark tank so no one
thought that would happen
um certainly most people thought
business would be boring yeah
that did not turn out to be the case i
remember the moment
that it all changed i'll never forget it
i think it was boston logan airport
i've been doing shark tank for three
years no one knew anything about it
nobody watched it it was just you know
the only people watching were two dogs
and a cat right that was about it
but all of a sudden in year four
something happened
you know it was the it was coming out of
that really big financial crisis in 2008
and entrepreneurship started to be very
hip and shark tank caught on and i was
i went to the uh i was with my wife and
daughter at um
at the airport and i went into men's
room and i you know
at the urinal doing my business and
there's a guy to my right two over
right and he kept looking at me and
and i noticed he kept looking at me and
he said are you that guy on shark tank
i said yeah that's the first time it
ever happened he said
you're an [ __ ] and i said why would
you say that i said last night in shark
tank you took 51
of a startup that's outrageous business
business i said hey it's my money i'll
cry if i want to what are you talking
about
i said to him listen uh a lot of people
make deals in bathrooms but not here
today my friend
right i'm going to run my business the
way i see i should 100
and he couldn't have known uh that linda
and savannah are out there
he goes outside and i find out later
that he said to linda
that [ __ ] kevin o'leary's in the
men's room i didn't know it was your
wife
no and she said i know oh my god
no it's really an amazing show and i
feel like before
shark tank entrepreneur meant unemployed
and now it really means like it's
you've shaped a culture around the word
and it's something people want to aspire
to be and start their own businesses and
i just love it
we do we love you talking about what
you've done here because
you're the girl that's basically telling
everybody you're unemployed yeah
you're a comedian um which is erratic
work to say the best and then you come
in here
you know with your sister every day and
you produce this which is actually been
very successful for you
so yes you're unemployed but you're
making money right it's a beautiful
poetic irony of it all
it is but i wonder how many millennials
now
even gen zirs are going to look at your
model both of you and say
i need to do that because i you have
control over your own destiny
yes i think we're living in a world
where kids today want to grow up to be
influencers podcasters because part of
the job is to make it look easy you know
take beautiful photos filter everything
what a lot of people don't see is
a lot of the job is boring paperwork
like you would do at any other nine to
five to job
but influencing is the one industry
that's literal sole purpose is to make
it look fabulous make it look fun make
it look easy make it look
you know easy road to money and fame
when in reality it's actually a lot of
work and
we do a daily podcast which is crazy
because most people do weekly podcasts
and i can't count on my hand the number
of podcasts that launch and never go
past 10 episodes
even producing one episode a week is
incredible hard work so it's just one of
those things that looks super easy
um and i think that's why a lot of
people want to do it it looks like it's
the you know the fast track to money and
fame
when in reality it's like actually the
opposite but it's more than that because
you know if you ask millennials eight
out of ten will say i'm going to be an
influencer
you can't just become an influencer the
market is really cruel that way
it it you have to have something about
you maybe
you know your story the fact that you're
a comic that
that gives the magnetism that creates an
interest for other people
most people don't have that yeah well
it's so saturated right now
like it's not only saturated breaking
through even if you have it is next to
impossible
yes getting your first million followers
is really
really hard let alone a hundred thousand
and so
you really can't get traction till you
get scale yes
yeah and what i've learned you know
dealing with all the influencers that i
deal with and the stuff we do
is that unfortunately for some people
um they don't realize early enough that
people smell [ __ ] a mile away
yes and you when you get cancelled
you're canceled
yeah you ain't coming back well we might
better
differ i actually whack them all we
wrote the book on cancellation and
cancel culture literally
and i actually disagree i think we're
living in a really interesting time
right now where it's like a rubber band
that's going to snap
i think that for a while it was that was
the case like if you had even a stinch
of scandal or controversy what about all
these people that got me tooed
well that's different yeah we try to
separate we try to separate
versus crime yes so we feel like cancer
culture is this huge bubble where we're
like always canceling people
for saying bad things and doing bad
things but actually the two of them are
incredibly different
if you were me too you are a criminal
like that is
separate we're talking about cancel
culture you know you have tweets
resurfaced from when you're in high
school you make a joke that not everyone
thinks is funny because you know we're
living in overly sensitive times like
that type of cancer culture is so toxic
because first of all it leaves no room
for
growth okay roseanne barr oh
um i'll tell you why i bring that one up
okay
she changed forever the morality
contracts in hollywood that i was
subject to
in subsequent contracts your you know
the story just so we bring it to viewers
to understand here
and and i want to hear your response
because you're saying not necessarily
right
she did she said something very off
color yes
very that was her comedy 10 years ago
yes okay um
the network that was sponsoring the
number one show had 80 million i think
68 million worth of up
advertising the ceo canceled it an hour
and a half later
gave all the money back to the
advertisers yeah cancelled the show
that's extreme yes because i do think
her tweet was incredibly
wrong and it was where does it fit in
your continuum i'm trying to press the
we like to say that every cancellation
is not one size fits all i need to know
all the details so
you know for that for that roseanne
thing like she was a however old she is
like a 50 year old woman like saying
something in present times
that she really should not have said
like i don't i actually think like her
being removed from the show was the best
thing for it
i don't know if the show needed to be
cancelled in its entirety there were
other people working on the show
120 people 100 yeah they brought it back
in
in a different format and i think a lot
of people got their jobs back but and
it's still on and it's successful
look i'm not endorsing what she said but
i'm pointing out to you that these
extremes on cancellation are
really serious yes and has materially
affected her ability to get back into
her business
yes and so it was horrible what she did
yes
that was her comedy yeah there has to be
consequence like we live in a time and i
think we've all kind of come to the
realization we live in a time
that's very different than the time that
was 10 years ago and we all need to
adjust and i think that if you're still
saying
certain things in this day and age like
there are consequences for what you say
but i don't think that people should be
held
to the same standard you make a joke in
2010 and it resurfaces in 2021
that's not fair we're living in
different times well then then you're
right in that case because
i don't think you can be sexist or
racist period
not now not back then not in the future
i don't think that's a good thing for
anybody
and i think that's what got her in real
trouble
because she took something that maybe
she thought could pass 10 years ago and
tried it out today and then
yeah done so you're the same i assume
comedy is a really interesting space
well that's what i wanted to probe into
right so comedy like most comedians have
podcasts and comedy and podcasting
couldn't be more different
comedy is no holds barred you
people fight for the right to say
whatever they want because it's a joke
and you should be able to make a joke
about anything
whereas podcasting comes from the
digital space and the digital space is
so sensitive there's many classic comics
that are really really
on the edge dave chappelle on the edge
on
sexist racist stuff like can you do you
can't do that anymore
no no i'm talking about comedy in the
comments vertical mind going into a club
and really laying it out there my
personal style of comedy
is very specific and intentional like i
do self-deprecating comedy i make fun of
myself
because no one can be mad at you if
you're making fun of yourself you're not
offending anyone i'm literally just
defending myself
okay so you think those comics have to
change
they can't do their traditional routines
anymore i think comedy is like the last
remaining corner of the
earth where you can say crazy things but
i don't think it'll last long
it's already very touchy you're saying
you won't last long
yeah one won't not still i think
a frontier that's in question i think
people are sticking up for
the right to joke about what you want to
joke about and then there are people who
are like we
you can't make jokes about that and i
think depending on the comedian or
depending on the celebrity or influencer
when we say like you can be canceled and
you can come back
you have to pull yourself up by the
bootstraps no corporation's going to
give you a job
no what brand is going to endorse you
like you need to make build your own
business for yourself
because the industry in the world that
we live in
is not going to give you the sense you
can't go into mainstream you have to do
it yourself
yes and you need to find your audience
and you like
you have to start from scratch and then
you build something
that is impenetrable you are in charge
of your own destiny no one can cancel
you because you own your own show
you make all your own revenue you make
your own merch like you don't rely on
any other company
into a larger company and we're you know
in these extremely sensitive times like
that's corporate culture yeah yeah i
think this
this this model you've developed for
yourselves actually proven it out
is is very desirable for many people
want to control their own destiny
yeah i think you work harder than you
would in a corporate environment you
have more risk in your life because you
don't know what can happen
you have to put up your own money when
you start it and you also may make one
mistake and get fried and have to start
again
yeah but the beautiful thing about the
internet is that like it's just the wild
west so you can do anything you want and
there's so many people on it like
we've just kind of cycled through so
many different stages of our business
we're entering a new one every week like
that's just you have to keep up with it
and like you have to shed your old skin
and just
keep moving forward if you want to stay
in this industry for a long time
i think you do don't you of course
you've bypassed
all the traditional media like it used
to be you'll never get on this network
again you'll never get this you'll never
get that and it was all controlled by
hollywood agents and all that stuff into
a certain extent television still is
that way
but you know i have more followers now
than
most of the networks i'm on yeah right
and and it's a strange phenomenon that
you know i can reposition that content
modify it somewhat and get to a brand
new audience in a different way
yeah i'm not sure the model doesn't keep
going in that direction
and that you know linear television
continues to decline as social you know
this is kind of like social network
itself
you know every influencer podcaster
whatever becomes their own little media
industry
and the bigger you get you do almost
have more reach think of like podcasting
verse radio radio is you know
huge a lot of podcasts reach more people
than
traditional radio shows do podcasts used
to be framed
you know what i like to i get invited on
a lot of podcasts including this one and
what i like to do
is resist the temptation to go look at
all the previous
podcasts i don't want to know anything
about you
when i show up here i mean i met you for
a few hours right on an island i thought
i was
thoroughly entertained but i want to go
in fresh
yeah and then later you know if we start
doing it over and over again i kind of
get the groove of where it is
but i've been much more successful doing
that in terms of engaging
and podcasts aren't just audio anymore
they're they're video yeah
that's what a podcast is it's just
another television show yeah literally
and my attitude is it's much fresher
when you go in cold yes i agree you know
i hate
all the scripted stuff and everything
else i just did the pomps podcast in
miami last week
we had a crazy amount of fun because we
said
no questions pre you know set yeah let's
just see what happens
yeah yeah that was fun that's the way it
should be definitely a refreshing format
you're not
bound by those restraints of even
cursing like something as simple as that
right time constraints like you can
really go for topic matter who knows
where you go right right exactly you
went from wine to roseanne barr
exactly but i think those are serious
issues let's go back to wine because i
want to
taste i want to try i want to give you
we're going to start with the
chardonnay even though it's not chilled
but this shard just won its
fifth gold award oh wow now let me tell
you something about the wine business
just before we pour this
97 percent of wine in america is sold
for
under 14.99 a bottle wow
nobody knows that that means three
percent which is virtually nothing is
are those expensive wines the challenge
becomes
how do you make a wine that tastes like
it's worth 60
that you can buy for 11. and i spent a
lot of time on this because i wanted my
return rates because i'm going direct to
consumer to be less than two percent
which was my goal
they're significantly less than one
percent wow so that means
i have to kind of adapt to the palette
most
women drink pinot grigio and chardonnay
that's
you know they drink whites yeah so you
need to work with a lot of women to
stamp
like i'll blend it i'll try it on my
wife try it on her friends then do
some serious taste testing sampling to
get the vibe from what a
miami woman says versus a california
woman versus somebody in champaign
urbana
to try and nail down do i have it
yeah because i'm i'm blending these
wines i'm adding little elements of
other varietals to get that flavor
about five years ago i hit it big when i
i
i started taking less you know when you
put chardonnay into an oak barrel
it gets buttery oaky and women were
moving away from that they were saying
give me something fresher it's too heavy
you know
and i went in that direction and then i
started winning the war cycle oh i'm so
excited to try this because i'm usually
not a huge
chardonnay fan but i love savion blanc
pinot grigio sounds fair
but if you're saying this isn't like a
buttery heavy chardonnay so i could be
way off in that direction which is
actually classic mantra shea style which
is what the french do in the drc region
of france
so let's try this how much is that
bottle this bottle uh tonight
the reason i'm talking about it uh when
we go public we're going to do a giant
sale on qvc
normally it would be 15.99 tonight it's
gonna be eleven dollars and twelve
cents 15.99 is still a great price it's
but that we're going to sell
i did something remarkable a few weeks
ago on qvc in 20 hours we sold
5.2 million dollars worth of wow wow
yeah did you work with laurie no i
worked with mr wonderful
wonderful i hear yeah no listen you know
i'm the wine guy in qvc now because i
think people trust me when i say i have
your back
i really know what i'm talking about i
would trust you like to choose a wine
for me will you also show us the right
way to taste wine without looking like a
fool
i absolutely great question we have
these we have these coveted glasses
which are fantastic yes
so normally you would never overfill a
glass of wine you have to leave enough
space
the air to mix with the wine so you can
swill it a little bit it turns out
it smells delightful yeah now let's do
this because this should be chilled but
it's not
because it came to the studio um
oh you know the nose you should be
picking up some apricot and apple here
yeah okay so now take a little bit and
just
let it roll back in the back of your
tongue
stunning nectar from the nipple of
aphrodite
no it's really delicious so good it's
fantastic i actually don't drink wine
but
crisp it is it's not over sweet it's
towards what you liked in the dryness
yes this is a monster for me this wine
is my number one seller in white
really it's delightful it is delicious
stunning color as well
yeah it's beautiful and so you know this
kind of wine would be fantastic with
cheese it would be great in the
summertime
terrific with chicken people like to
drink it i always drink a glass of white
at four o'clock when the market closes
and i have one sometimes two and then i
go to my reds
so we're going to go to red next okay
well this was
chardonnay it was good stunning and then
here
sometimes you can be a real stick your
pinky out like this when you're drinking
see that oh yeah because we're fancy
like that
exactly and you you know you're drinking
with a dork when you do that
yes someone uncultured yeah and now this
is a
cabernet sauvignon is known for being
the big spicy american red
you know for for with meat and just a
big bold statement
and what you're looking for here is um
peppers and tannins
and leather and just just richness
and get this by blending it again and so
many people don't understand that to get
the the tail of the flavor
you have to you know maybe you sneak in
two percent pinot
or maybe you put in a syrah or something
you have to blend you have to sit
in the cellar for days with your
testimony
and try different stuff while not
getting inebriated because you
start you stop sensing the flavor so
most of the time i'm tasting one
spitting it out
spittoon so here we go now this is going
to have a huge nose
also five different awards on this one
oh wow
the red wine with the white carpet yeah
pink and white
yeah yeah what a disaster should be a
splash of tie-dye yeah
when's the last time you did a wine
tasting here never never we've never
done it on the show
okay so here we go it's good to start
with the best it can only go down from
here
yeah all right so again
we really want to you know definitely
yeah i don't want to see that drop yeah
okay
now this is going to have
um a peppery kind of spice to it and the
more if you waited 10 minutes it would
even be more
bold because it's just airing this is
going to be really good i can tell
okay let's go ready
oh wow ichi
that is fantastic it's very good it is
you know i never drink red wine
but it's very good isn't that delicious
yeah people tell me all the time i
really taste the pepper
yeah you see it it's there that took a
long long many years i've been doing
this wine for seven different years
of different varietals and started
winning about four years ago
when i started blending but you know you
got to try new things in wine
and by the way the health attributes of
one glass of red
a year a day forever all year long
works in longevity yes it's good for
your heart everything and so you don't
have to get drunk you can just drink one
glass of nine ounces of red wine a day
and almost consider it medicine you also
could get drunk if you want
well that happens to me quite often
oops all right so where can everyone buy
oh larry wines on qvc you're having a
big sale
well there's what i've learned is this
is the business side again
wine is three tiers of distribution so i
used to give all my profits to
distributors
then i learned how to sell direct when i
got my social chops together and i
started small but now i'm huge
so you can buy o'leary fine wines at
shop mr wonderful
starting tonight at midnight wow we'll
do our big sale and that
site's going to stay up forever we're
announcing it at the nasdaq at four
you're getting a sneak peek
this won't be up until tomorrow anytime
on qvc.com fabulous
largest purveyor of wine and we ship it
to you directly
wow that's pretty awesome
it is great a lot of people go on to the
program where they get shipped a case
every 60 days
excuse me they sit they put it in a in a
like a laid down kind of wine cellar box
you stick it in the back of your closet
boom you got wine all the time for
forever yeah yeah well it's delicious
thank you so much for being here yes you
can uh keep up with kevin obviously on
shark tank on instagram
kevin o'leary tv on youtube and
that's our show thank you so much for
being here we enjoyed it one more sip
please cheers to us that's great cheers
what's fun what fun cheers thank you
guys for watching we'll see you tomorrow
bye
you